i've done the seven-day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran by seven
day free trial bonuses no credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
world war iii is it about to start we
don't know
now what we do know and with this video
what i wanted to do is reflect upon what
allah said in the quran to the angels
because the angels
questioned allah they asked the question
um angels by their nature are they do as
they are told
but some of us think that they can't
really you know ask a question in this
very eye in surah verse 30
is asked a question
and he says
rem
remember
talking to the prophet sallam when your
lord said to the angels i am going to
place a successive human
authority on earth they asked allah will
you place in it someone who will spread
corruption there and shed blood while we
glorify your praise and proclaim your
holiness allah responded i know what you
don't know
he taught adam the names of all things
then he preserved then he presented them
to the angels and said tell me the names
of these if that if what you say is true
they replied glory be to you we have no
knowledge except what you have taught us
you are truly or knowing or wise so
allah subhanahu wa is teaching the
angels a lesson now how does this tie in
with the whole um war that's happening
between russia and ukraine
now the thing is here brothers and
sisters that the angels talked about
human beings and
how we are by nature because the khalifa
that he was going to place on earth
which this word is known for somebody
who's going to carry out justice and you
know speak out against oppression
so they knew what kind of creatures were
going to be
and they asked allah question now what
do we learn from this very important
very small this little soul
is the following that they said allah
we proclaim your purity we worship you
we don't disobey you
logically why would you want to make a
creation who's going to cause bloodshed
on earth now this is very important
because it ties beautifully to the issue
of satan shaytan iblees and adam
al-salam because iblees refused to bow
down why because he logically said
that i am better than him now they're
both if you think about it using some
part of their rationale to be like okay
this does not make sense however if you
look at iblees iblis fell into disbelief
because he actually questioned allah and
blamed allah for his disbelief and his
transgression the angels are doing the
same thing while allah responds with
something which should make us all
remember something allah saying that he
is aware that that will happen of course
he knows more than the angels that's
going to happen but i know
something you don't now if you guys
would maybe um resonate with this a lot
of times when wars happen a lot of
people ask these questions atheists
people who don't believe in god if god
exists why did the bloodshed why does
this happen etc it's a common question
this really ties in beautifully to this
ayah but allah saying i know what you
don't know so there might be some things
to us to our rationale to our logic well
that doesn't make sense why would god do
that we have two options
to rebel or to submit
this is this is what makes difference it
makes us different from following iblees
or being those who are obedient like
there are things that's going to happen
though it doesn't make sense to us
there's going to be bloodshed on earth
like the angel said
but you need to put your trust
in
the knuckle which is text the divine
text where allah ordered et cetera
rather than the
this doesn't mean we don't use akka the
point i'm trying to make here is this
we do not override our logic over what
allah has prescribed is knuckle this is
very important very very fundamental
whenever you're faced with anything
calamity things don't make sense etc
just know and put your trust in allah
because it's a matter of tawakkul yeah
and shaytan didn't have that tawakkal
that's why he fell into disbelief and
this can lead you to disbelief so know
that the angels and allah knew what is
going to happen bloodshed is going to
happen but
you can choose to be among those who are
obedient and trust allah or be among
those who are disobedient like iblis and
not trust allah this is the only thing
that i wanted to share with you guys in
this time of climate and you can use
this any way you like
take the knuckle over the acl the text
over
what your brain or your rationale tells
you because there are things that allah
knows that we don't know he's the most
wise the all-knowing that's all i wanted
to share with you guys today brothers
and sisters inshallah until next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
please share this with your friends and
family inshallah so they benefit too